en este vídeo quiero ver si podemos
graficar una función racional recordemos
que una función racional es simplemente
una expresión que tiene un polinomio en
el numerador y en el denominador por
ejemplo podemos tener que igual a un
polinomio x al cuadrado dividido entre
otro polinomio le voy a poner x al
cuadrado menos 16
y en realidad ya sabemos cómo graficar
estas funciones utilizando una tabla
verdad podemos poner algunos valores de
prueba a ver cuánto nos queda y pasar
eso a la gráfica eso es lo que haría una
calculadora que gráfica haría valores de
prueba y los pondría pero ahorita quiero
platicar de algunas técnicas que nos
ayudan para entender la estructura
básica de la gráfica cuando tenemos una
función racional vale bueno lo primero
que quiero platicar es qué sucede cuando
x se hace muy muy grande ya sea muy
grande positivo o muy grande negativo o
sea que es lo que le sucede allí cuando
el valor absoluto de x se va a infinito
cuando x se hace muy grande
magnitud vale bueno para estudiar esto
voy a sacar la calculadora para probar
algunos valores déjame encenderla
entonces vamos a poner valores de x pues
así algunos chiquitos y luego otros más
grandes vale empecemos con x igual a 10
entonces si ponemos x igual a 10
aquí nos queda 10 al cuadrado 10 al
cuadrado dividido entre 10 al cuadrado
menos 16 menos 16 va nos queda 1.19
todavía no sabemos muy bien qué sucede
vamos a poner un valor de x más grande
digamos x igual a 100 entonces hacemos
100 al cuadrado entre 100 al cuadrado
100 al cuadrado menos 16
entonces aquí nos queda 11.00 16 observa
que hasta ahorita son valores positivos
ahorita vemos qué sucede con los
negativos que va a ser más o menos lo
mismo porque aquí estamos elevando al
cuadrado pero ahorita platicamos de eso
bueno entonces nos queda 1.001 y esto se
va acercando a 1
entonces parece ser que nos acercamos a
1 vamos a ver si es cierto déjame
meterle x igual a 1000 elevamos al
cuadrado y dividimos entre 1000 al
cuadrado 1000 al cuadrado y al cuadrado
menos 16
le damos enter y si en efecto nos
acercamos a 1 antes teníamos 1.001 pero
ahora es 1.000 0 16 eso está súper cerca
de 1 entonces cuando x se hace muy
grande tenemos que ya se va se va a 1 y
bueno algo parecido sucede cuando aquí
se hace grande negativo ahorita sólo
hicimos grande positivo pero con grande
negativo pasa lo mismo porque digamos
aquí en vez de tener un 100 tendríamos
un menos 100 pero menos 100 al cuadrado
lo mismo que 100 al cuadrado y aquí pasa
lo mismo menos 100 al cuadrado es lo
mismo que si en al cuadrado entonces
también tenemos este número de acá y por
lo tanto cuando se hace con perdón
cuando x se hace grande negativo que
también se va a 1 vale bueno entonces ya
se va a 1 es decir la gráfica de la
función y esta de acá x al cuadrado
entre x al cuadrado menos 16 se acerca a
la gráfica de la función y igual a 1 así
que déjame dibujarla acá porque va a ser
una gráfica auxiliar como no es la
gráfica de la función sino una gráfica
auxiliar la voy a poner aquí punteada
nada más vale entonces esto que estoy
pintando esta línea punteada azul es la
gráfica de la función ye yé igual a
y lo que sucede es que la gráfica que
nos interesa se acerca mucho mucho mucho
a esta línea pero nunca la toca y esta
idea de que tenemos una línea que se
acerca mucho a la gráfica que nos
interesa pero que nunca se tocan se le
conoce como a sin total es decir esta
recta la recta ye igual a 1 es una cinta
para la gráfica de nuestra función no
voy a escribir aquí a la 5ta
en total vale y como es una línea
horizontal pues esto se conoce como una
asín total sin azúcar un poco feo a sin
tota horizontal horizontal cuando no
está muy creativo pero bueno haciendo
está horizontal sale va ahorita quiero
platicar de otra cosa ahorita ponemos la
gráfica para que estos entiendo un poco
más pero antes de eso me gustaría
platicar de qué sucede cuando el
denominador se hace cero entonces para
eso voy a factorizar lo entonces voy a
reescribir esto como x al cuadrado entre
aquí tenemos una diferencia de cuadrados
entonces la puedo factorizar como x más
4 x x menos 4 x 4 entonces quiero ver
qué sucede con cuando x se acerca a 4
bueno a 4 o al menos 4 bueno o sea
primero que sucede si x es igual a 4 o
menos 4 por ejemplo si x es igual a 4
esta expresión x menos 4 se hace 0
entonces estamos dividiendo entre 0 y
por lo tanto ahí la función está
indefinida vale entonces
la división entre 0 no nos permite hacer
cosas de modo que la función está
indefinida en 4 y lo mismo pasa en menos
4 voy a escribirlo por acá voy a poner
que ya está indefinida está indefinida
indefinida
4 y menos 4 porque en esos valores
tendríamos que dividir entre 0 pero no
sabemos cómo hacer eso vale bueno ya que
está indefinida ahí puede que sea
interesante ver qué sucede cuando nos
acercamos a esos valores por ejemplo
casi por pura diversión vamos a ver qué
sucede si nos acercamos a menos 4
digamos por la izquierda entonces vamos
a vamos a poner vamos a estudiar qué
pasa cuando aquí se va a -4 por por la
izquierda
vale entonces vamos a la calculadora por
ejemplo quiero ver qué sucede en menos
4.0 dejame borrar entonces tenemos menos
4.0 me lo voy a poner 4.1 vale menos 4.1
al cuadrado y vamos a dividir entre
menos 4.1
al cuadrado creo que voy a necesitar más
paréntesis aquí verdad
y aquí está el paréntesis a menos 4.1 al
cuadrado menos 16 ok si es eso lo que
quiero si va entonces le doy enter y
observa tenemos 20 puntos 75 30 todavía
no sabemos muy bien qué sucede vamos a
poner un valor más cercano a menos 4
entonces quién va a ser la tos o déjame
déjame copiar la entrada anterior y aquí
simplemente voy a poner un cero entonces
menos 4.01 al cuadrado menos 4 punto
pero al cuadrado pero si lo que quería 0
y aquí necesito un paréntesis al
cuadrado está ok ok todo bien me parece
que sí vale entonces le damos enter y
ven ahora tenemos un valor mayor de 20
pasamos a 200 seguirá creciendo pues
vamos a ver vamos a probar 4.200 1 bueno
menos 4.00 una vez más le doy insert y
le pongo un 0 me voy para cada otra vez
insertar le pongo otro 0 le doy enter y
lo que quería
enter y b2000 creció todavía más
entonces pues al parecer cuando nos
acercamos más y más a menos 4 obtenemos
valores más y más grandes y por lo tanto
nos vamos a infinito de hecho tú lo
puedes probar en tu propia calculadora
puedes intentar menos 4.000 0001 para
ver qué sucede pero bueno ya que lo
pruebes vas a ver que en efecto cuando x
se va al menos 4 por la izquierda
entonces tenemos que ya que se va a
infinito toma valores cada vez más
grandes como le hacemos para indicar eso
en nuestra figura pues lo que vamos a
hacer es más es marcar marcar ahora la
recta x igual a menos 4 1 2 3 4 aquí
está x igual a menos 4 es igual a menos
4 vale entonces la función no va a estar
definida en x igual a menos 4 no tenemos
ningún punto de la gráfica sobre esta
recta pero lo que acabamos de ver es que
si nos acercamos a menos 4 por aquí está
menos éste es igual a menos 4 si nos
acercamos a menos 4 por la izquierda
entonces la gráfica de la función se va
a infinito eso lo podemos combinar con
lo que vimos acá arriba y ya vamos
teniendo una idea de cómo se ve la
gráfica lo voy a pintar con este color
verde verde así vale entonces cuando nos
vamos a menos infinito la función se va
a 1 cuando nos acercamos a menos 4 la
función se va a infinito entonces
tenemos algo más o menos
más o menos
sí vale entonces empieza en menos uno y
luego crece y crece y crece y crece y se
va a infinito va ahora vamos a ver qué
sucede del otro lado cuando x es igual a
4 déjame pintar por aquí la línea x
igual a 4
4 través le estoy poniendo punteada
porque nada más es una auxiliar estar
acá es igual a 4 y vamos a ver qué pasa
cuando nos acercamos a x igual a 4 por
la derecha en realidad eso lo que quiere
decir es que estamos probando valores
como 4.01 como 4.001 etcétera etcétera
pero eso ya lo hicimos bueno básicamente
porque aquí pusimos menos 4.01 pero si
ponemos 4.0 uno va a dar exactamente lo
mismo porque estamos elevando al
cuadrado es la misma idea de hace rato
es decir la gráfica es simétrica con
respecto al eje y va entonces con esto
en mente también podemos decir que en
este caso que se va a infinito que se va
a infinito y entonces pasa algo similar
entonces ahora como nos quedaría pues
ahora empezamos aquí en infinito bueno
si nos acercamos a cuatro por la derecha
nos vamos infinito
ahora la gráfica baja
y otra vez cuando x se va a infinito en
magnitud de entonces nos acercamos a la
gráfica de d
igual a 1 y a estas dos rectas que ahora
son rectas verticales y con las cuales
la función queda indefinida pero nos
vamos a infinito o menos infinito como
ahorita vamos a ver a estas también se
le llaman asiento estás solo que ahora
se les conoce como a sin total a sin
total verticales a sin total así sin ese
acento está feo así todas
las cintas verticales verticales
muy bien entonces vamos súper bien ya
entendimos que sucede de este lado
izquierdo de este lado derecho nos
acercamos a que igual a 1 cuando x hace
grande ahora lo que estaría padre es
entender qué sucede aquí adentro en el
intervalo menos 4,4 por ejemplo qué
sucede si ahora nos acercamos a 4 a 4 no
por la izquierda sino por la derecha
pues saquemos la calculadora vamos a
seguir jugando vale entonces aquí está
la calculadora ahora lo que queremos son
lo que queremos son valores cercanos a 4
pero por la por la izquierda un poquito
más chiquitos que 4 por ejemplo podemos
probar con 3.9 3.9 al cuadrado anual la
cuarta no al cuadrado entonces eso lo
queremos dividir entre 3.9 3.9 que crees
que suceda bueno ahorita vemos 3.9 al
cuadrado menos 16
ahora nos queda menos 19.25 vamos a
poner la expresión de arriba y nos vamos
a acercar más aquí vamos a poner otro 9
para acercarnos más a 4 menos 33.9 ahí
tenemos otro 3.9 ok le damos enter y
observa ahora nos fuimos a menos 199 es
un valor grande pero negativo ahora
ahora al parecer nos vamos a ir a menos
infinito vamos a ver si es cierto
probando con con un valor más entonces
aquí vamos a poner otro 9 más cerca de 4
otro 9 más cerca de 4 le damos enter y
si ahora nos vimos a menos 1999 como
menos 2000 entonces en efecto cuando nos
acercamos más y más a 4 ahora nos
estamos yendo hacia menos infinito
entonces voy a boya
déjame agarrar el color verde entonces
la gráfica ahora nos quedaría como algo
así ahora al acercarnos a este valor nos
queda menos infinito al acercarnos a 4
por la derecha entonces sería algo más o
menos así
y de modo similar como la gráfica es
simétrica con respecto al eje y por esto
de elevar al cuadrado
tenemos que cuando nos acercamos a menos
4 por la izquierda también nos vamos a
menos infinito otra vez puedes probarlo
en la calculadora pero es la misma idea
como elevamos al cuadrado no nos
importan tanto los hitos vale entonces
ya sabemos cómo se comporta la función
alrededor de la sas into estás cuando x
es muy grande ya nada más vamos a probar
pues un valor un valor adicional para
ver qué sucede justo aquí y un valor
pues que parece ser muy bueno para
probarlo es el cero verdad porque queda
justo a la mitad entonces vámonos acá
ahora si ponemos un valor particular nos
quedaría cero
aquí nos quedaría cero dividido entre 0
16 entre menos 16 y aquí no hay problema
verdad cero entre cualquier cosa que no
sea cero es igual a cero y de esta forma
el punto cero cero está en la gráfica de
la función es decir podemos hacer esto
y nos queda más o menos algo así claro
podríamos probar algunos puntos más para
entender bien bien qué sucede aquí en
medio pero ahorita ya tenemos una idea
muy buena de cómo se ve la gráfica de la
función ya tenemos un esbozo súper padre
bueno antes de seguir déjame reflexionar
un poquito aquí alrededor de las asiento
estás usamos la calculadora para
entender si nos íbamos a infinito o
menos infinito pero en realidad
podríamos reflexionar un poco más y
entender por qué sucede por ejemplo no
sé vamos a acercarnos a cuatro o sea si
nos acercamos a cuatro este término de
acá el término x menos cuatro pues cada
vez va a ser más y más y más y más
chiquito porque como x está muy cerca de
4 la diferencia va a ser muy pequeña
entonces va a ser un término chiquito
que puede ser positivo o negativo
dependiendo de que el lado de 4 estemos
pero bueno dividir entre algo muy
chiquito es algo muy muy muy grande
positivo o negativo vale entonces si
tenemos esta expresión y la
multiplicamos por algo muy grande nos va
a quedar algo muy muy grande entonces
pues básicamente
básicamente nos queda algo muy grande
dependiendo de qué helado estemos
entonces si estamos a la derecha aquí
nos queda algo positivo algo positivo
esto es positivo esto es positivo
entonces algo muy grande positivo se va
infinito y de modo similar acercándonos
por la izquierda este es negativo esto
es positivo y tenemos que se va a menos
infinito vale entonces esa es la idea
detrás de eso va entonces ya además para
reflexionar que hicimos hicimos lo
siguiente primero determinamos la 5ta
horizontal y para eso metimos valores en
la calculadora en realidad pues pudimos
haber metido un valor todavía más grande
como diez mil millones y seguro nos
hubiera salido más rápido pero esto
también se puede reflexionar a partir de
esta expresión básicamente lo que sucede
es que si aquí se hace muy muy grande
entonces estos términos de acá los x al
cuadrado crecen mucho más rápido que
este 16
este 16 básicamente ya no importa
entonces lo que acaba sucediendo
sí sí x se va a infinito en magnitud y
es aproximadamente aproximadamente x al
cuadrado entre x al cuadrado y esto por
supuesto es 1 entonces eso lo que nos
dice es que para valores de x muy
grandes el 16 ya no nos importa y bueno
esto es un poco más general o sea
podemos pensar que aquí hay un 1 y aquí
hay un 1 y entonces al hacer esta
división básicamente estamos dividiendo
estos coeficientes y pues no se desea
que hubiéramos tenido 2 x al cuadrado
más bien habría que hacer la división 2
entre 1 nos quedaría que la 5ta
horizontales ya igualados
no sé si arriba tuviéramos 1 y abajo
menos 2
entonces la asiento está horizontal
sería igual a menos un medio vale vale
entonces esto es lo que sucede cuando
tienen el mismo grado aquí escuadra tico
y aquí escuadra tico pero ojo si tienen
grados distintos pasan otras cosas si el
grado del denominador es más grande que
el del numerador entonces dividimos
entre algo más grande y la siendo está
va a estar en cero después de los
ejemplos de eso y también está el otro
caso cuando el grado
cuando el grado de el numerador es más
grande en cuyo caso importa más lo que
hace el numerador y ahí nos vamos a
infinito o menos infinito como pasaba
con los polinomios verdad un polinomio
es una expresión racional donde el
denominador es 1 nos vamos a infinito o
menos infinito bueno esto es para la 5ta
horizontal y para las cintas verticales
la regla es un poquito más complicada es
básicamente lo que hicimos hay que
determinar cuando se anula el
denominador pero además hay que cuidar
que no se que no se cancele con nada de
el numerador si no se cancela con nada
entonces ya estamos tenemos una cinta
vertical ahí pero podría pasar no sé
déjame poner un ejemplo que aquí arriba
tuviéramos un x menos 4 entonces aquí
también lo tendríamos
entonces en este caso este término se
cancelaría con este y en realidad no
tenemos un asiento está ahí de todas
formas la función está indefinida en x
igual a 4 pero ya no sería así en total
vale pero bueno ese es un caso raro del
cual voy a platicar con más calma
después por el momento no teníamos estos
x menos 4 es más déjame dejame borrarlos
así menos 4 ahí está teníamos nada más
esta expresión y bueno entonces la idea
es esa si el denominador se anula y en
el numerador no hay nada que lo cancele
entonces ahí tenemos una cinta vertical
uff ya dijimos muchísimas cosas pero
nada más para terminar déjame hacer una
última cosa vamos a verificar que en
efecto la gráfica de la función se ve
así vamos a sacar la calculadora vamos a
sacarla y ahora sí vamos a meternos a la
función de graficar entonces vamos a
poner la expresión que tenemos la
expresión es x al cuadrado x al cuadrado
/ / x al cuadrado
al cuadrado menos 16 y con un poco de
suerte se va a parecer a estar chinche
que dibujamos por acá entonces vamos a
darle graficar guau guau nos quedó casi
igualito bueno aquí está un poco más
plano pero ve es exactamente la misma
idea de hecho ahí está tienen pintadas
usa si no estás creo que más bien es
porque la calculadora intenta completar
ahí la función pero bueno podemos pensar
las con más síntomas ojo en realidad no
son parte de la gráfica sólo son rectas
auxiliares para saber cómo graficar la
pero ver es básicamente la misma idea
cuando x es grande negativo aquí tienen
su asiento está horizontal en de igual a
1 está ya igual a 1 luego vamos
avanzando al llegar a menos 4 al llegar
a menos 4 este término es negativo este
es muy chiquito entonces todo esto es
grande entonces aquí nos queda aquí nos
queda algo positivo verdad grande
positivo si porque estoy acá a este es
negativo y éste también entonces más
bien baja menos por menos es más nos
queda negativo al cruzar menos 4
entonces ahora éste este cambio de signo
se hacen
activo pero sigue estando muy cerca de 4
entonces que era menos infinito en el 0
se hace 0 se apaga la calculadora en el
0 se hace 0 luego al acercarnos a 4 nos
vamos a menos infinito luego a infinito
bueno ahí tenemos la 5ta y finalmente
cuando x se hace grande positivo otra
vez aquí se ve el comportamiento
asintóticos hacia allí igual a 1 uf este
ejercicio estuvo kilométrico pero espero
que te haya gustado y que te hayas
divertido mucho